hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
have done a lot a lot a whole lot in the
background and that mostly means I was
just farming a whole bunch but also I
finally conquered it I was for those of
you who don't know the reason I didn't
have a welder and I knew about the
welder was because I had a bug in the
game that was not enabling me to get
crash powder no matter how many of those
explode ease I encountered and dodged
and went back to the base I wasn't
getting crash powder but I finally found
some I don't have it's because a new
build come out or something but I
finally got some out of one of those
things I have to crash powder now so the
first thing I'm gonna do and yes my
seamoth is still here I realized very
quickly after that I named the episode
that uh something bonked into me right
before that and I had 4% health left
so my seamoth the [ __ ] a duck the USS
[ __ ] a duck is somehow leaking bubbles
in air and I don't know why it do that
but that not do the sponges do so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to build this
welding tool that you guys have been
begging me to build and I know I know I
know I know about it but I have crash
powder right here I need to make
magnesium which takes three salt
magnesium what was it was magnesium
crash powder and titanium so that's easy
I've got a whole a whole bunch I've got
you can see I've got brand new lockers
that one's empty this one's full of
titanium quartz this one's full of
copper gold and silver this one's full
of titanium this one's full of titanium
this one's full of titanium and random
miscellaneous junk including those
torpedoes which I will build when I get
that torpedo system which is on my goal
but for right now I need this welder
because finally everyone will love me
and be my friend in the ocean where I am
lonely and have no friends or anyone
that could possibly be a friend and also
some people said that there was a secret
island that I could get to and that
would be very very interesting if I
could get to there I've never
a lot of the possibility that there
would be a man but I have this so this
probably means is it working do you feel
it yet mr. krabs that was not the quote
whoa I [ __ ] that one up can you feel
it now mr. Krabs right let's try this I
probably got to get it in the ocean
first don't bonk into nothing okay here
we go
ah there we go there we go there we go
that's the stuff oh that's good
somehow the glass is magically repairing
itself awesome oh um and if I oh if I
swim around with this thing it charges
it for me so that's awesome oh it's
fully healed now half a hundred percent
oh yeah look at this look at me I'm
making progress I'm doing good stuff
with my life well not not good stuff but
you know I'm playing subnautica and I'm
playing it marginally better than I was
before so that's a win in my book okay
so now for this particular episode I
wanted to work from home a little bit
and that means that I have some things
Oh where'd my let's go ahh wait no god
no oh god everything's blown I blew it I
blew it okay here we go alright so what
I have here and what I setup and what
the idea that I had is because I started
assembling a lot of lockers and I was
gonna quickly run out of names from my
own little guys and I totally remember
their names now and I don't have to
listen him out don't ask me to do that
but anyway I thought it would be a cool
idea I've been reading the comments of
you from you guys and that's how I found
out about the secret island but there's
some people that I wanted to pick
randomly pretty much just because they
had nice comments and I either laughed
or appreciate what they had to say
and I'm gonna name them on my locker on
this wall of awesome people so we got
Yuki Sakai which I'm hoping is a
Japanese name and then Christine Willy
Christine W is what was going to be
Christine Willy and then we got Parker
Murphy Park Parker Murph Murph
Parker mr. F
the best second dude sorry burger and
then we got Steven Smith Steven we got
we got Steve Steve Steven Smith Steven
Smith so thank you guys so much for
commenting so regularly and being
relatively nice instead of all the other
people who are just like stupid and I'm
like well gosh you know but my game was
all buggy and whatever anyway so thank
you everybody who commented and thank
you for now being on my wall of heroes
and there's more and more lockers that
are going to be filled up because in
between episodes I'm gonna be doing a
lot of farming and in this particular
episode what I wanted to do is now that
it's just about to break daylight
probably I wanted to work on making my
sad little base into a nice big happy
base the only problem being I like an
idiot built my foundation onto this one
lonely platform and there's absolutely
nothing to stand my platform on in the
abyss around me so I'm gonna have to
find a way to do that as oh oh that's
handy
oh that's so handy I can just slap it on
there that is perfect okay so now that
makes my life a lot easier cuz now I
could just slap it around and hope for
the best
whereas before I actually had to try and
work at things oops
put the hatch back okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to haul base now
oh that's not a lot of hole strength so
I need to get a lot of base materials
into my inventory and there's a bunch of
stuff I've got silicone rubber they
actually changed the recipe for silicone
rubber it's now made from creepvine of
all things so you have to get to
creepvine to make one silicone rubber
I'm imagining is because they just had
too many things being made out of quartz
and that wasn't doing good um the first
thing I'm gonna do is I'm actually gonna
deconstruct this because this corridor
is not necessary because I just needed
to connect to another area so I'm gonna
deconstruct this
so that I have some space because the
corridor is not 100% necessary you can
as was evident by that you can just slap
on another room and that's gonna be good
so I kind of want this to be it's gonna
be like a circular hub is what I have in
mind but that's not necessarily what's
gonna happen so we're just gonna hope
for the best because this this isn't
even this isn't even remotely close to
where it's supposed to be what was I
thinking when I built this base it's
it's not even it's not even all my
inventory is full x 344 okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna build foundation
out in logical places where they're
supposed to be because apparently I can
do that that is nice
that doesn't even need to be attached to
anything at all that is lovely
I like that okay so now I just need to
build a grid pattern to make my base a
lot stronger but someone said someone
said why is that not why is that not do
why is it not do do the dance
Oh God do the dance okay someone said
that the bigger you build your face the
more chance you have of being attacked
and that doesn't sound good because the
only thing I know that can attack me is
large and in charge and has a lot of
teeth and murders me very badly because
I didn't know this but that's why
there's a whole system of HP on your
base and that's why there's so many
things to worry about when you're
building your basement
did you guys hear that
okay there's so many things to worry
about when your pace is being built so
with that in mind I really shouldn't
have built my my my hub like right in
the middle of the foundation because
that often that kind of restricts me
from where else I'm building but that's
beside the point
okay so this is better because now we
have actual logical foundations with
support then up they're gone no need for
support structures here apparently we're
just gonna do it floaty style okay
either way now we have actual legit
things so the other thing that I need to
do is because this is not going to be
the observation area I'm going to make
the observation area one more out from
here so I'm just gonna make one more
foundation here and then then it should
be good and then I'll go and get more
stuff and then I should make I'm gonna
make an aquarium in the middle no I'm
gonna make an aquarium over there
connect another room here new maybe I'm
not there's so many decision to make I'm
trying to think how would that work is
that something I can do holy crap that's
kind of cool what work I'd have to move
the solar panels on it but that's really
cool oh I know what I'm gonna do oh I
know what I'm gonna do and I need an a
molasses the observation room oh that is
cool oh that is cool okay I'll be right
back I need to go get an amal which
means i need to go get bitten time to
get my ass full of holes even though it
kind of is already don't read too much
into that don't ask questions you don't
want the answers to
come on come out wherever you are
bite my CMOS I'll Ram it into your teeth
don't even think about thinking twice
about the fact that I'm gonna ram like
boat in your mouth where the hell are
they
Oh warrior there you are come bite me
[ __ ] Mon dude by me she dead
this is he dead is he dead Oh God he
doesn't look so good oh man
what I happen am dude are you are you
dying
did I kill you with my seamoth oh my god
I'm sorry
oh he's oh oh I feel bad Fung geez Oh
God he's stuck in me
oh he's in me oh he's inside me okay Wow
he does not look good best keep ramming
into him harder and harder Oh God I feel
look I'm just doing him a mercy
it's like mercy killing him cuz he's in
pain oh god damn it just cuz I got a
welder doesn't mean I need to start
slamming my seamoth around thank you
okay that's all I need for now I think I
got six so six means that I can make
multiple pieces of enameled glass I
don't know how many - how many but I
need at least three to make the
observation room
okay here we go he played used up what I
used up my darts assist blade oh man I
can't believe my fifth Lord blade is
dead
what was the point of even having a Sith
Lord lightsaber blade what the hell are
these seriously what the hell are the
creature eggs how if I build an aquarium
can I put them in there because that's
the only thing that I could possibly
think of that I would be able to use
that for that is bizarre okay anyway I'm
gonna put these in let's see Stephen
Smith that's kind of full Christine
you're kind of full at the moment Parker
or any of you empty ahh
youkai youqi youqi you you hold onto
these creature eggs for me they're
probably gonna hatch and consume your
face but that's besides the point it's a
worthy sacrifice okay so now I need to
make enamel glass which means that first
I need to make glass okay I think I need
three pieces so I need to make III think
I have glass actually ready-made I
believe so enamel glass
I can make a total of six pieces of an
amiable ass that's good okay so watch
this not that you can literally watch
anything else unless you're working on
other stuff while you're watching a
Barca by our video Oh dare you talk to
me at all times or else all come to the
computer and hug you cuz I would never
hurt you I'm going to build another
multi-purpose room right over here on
the edge on the precipice to destruction
the press of Heth into the abyss boink
okay so that multi-purpose room is up
but now on top of this multi-purpose
room I'm going to build an observer oh I
don't have the observer damnit
can I do it anyway can I do it anyway
can I do it I can do it oh it's gonna be
in the precipice to the abyss yes Oh oh
my god that looks so cool oh it's so
cool yes this is gonna hang off into
nothingness never touching anything it's
perfect it's not exactly perfect but
it's good enough and that's good enough
for markiplier okay so I'm gonna make
another the thing that I wanted to do
that I was actually tickled by is the
fact that you can do this which is
rather interesting I'm not sure what the
benefit of this would be besides sucking
more health out of mine the whole base
ring now four point three right exactly
what I wanted okay so I'm gonna make a
I'm gonna make it a hatch to get in
maybe
oh [ __ ] I'm out of glass oh I put all my
stocks in enamel glass and it crashed so
I lost everything okay but a good thing
I got plenty of quarts in stock pile so
I can make money up
yes how does this work first of all how
does that work I don't even where is it
it's it's not even here it's this on top
of here it says the lower ceiling and
just sadness no no it's about the same
ceiling it's something top of here oh
it's cool oh that's cool oh that's cool
it's so scary oh it's so scary oh it
just drops off into nothingness whenever
I build another base farther out it's
gonna be nuts if I build one of these
I'm gonna see the attack coming head-on
I want to see the giant sea creature try
to eat me alive
oh boy oh man eventually I'll be able to
make a gun and try to protect myself but
until that time comes I'm going to be
schooled I'm going to be so dead I'm
gonna be okay so there's got to be like
Oh connecting two floors oh yes yes
leave
okay so connecting two floors and I do
it can I do this gonna do this what can
I do this
all right in the center that's awesome
okay all right little I'm a little
excited because this is awesome this is
legitimately it's freaking awesome this
is this is legitimately cool to me to me
probably not to you guys but this is
legitimately interesting to me oh man
that's so cool next up I'm probably
gonna need to get you wait oh wait since
I didn't need the observatory the
aquarium large aquarium oh yes yes oh
yes yes yes I'm gonna put the creature
eggs in this so good maybe I can put it
on top of the observatory oh oh that
would be interesting
it's a large aquarium ah not no such
luck ah
no such luck on this one where am I
gonna put it
wait do I put this inside of a room do I
put this inside my base at work how
would that work
Oh tell me how it's gonna work oh this
so cool do I put it in here no yes maybe
so how does this work where does this go
all I want to know a hatch to enter it
sounds like it needs to go outside on a
foundation but it didn't seem to want to
do please tell me I can do this oh how
do I do
Oh
ah I need to build another I need to
build another room because I'm not gonna
put it in my main room just because I
don't have enough space there but I will
put it off to the side I have to move my
modification station but that's fine my
modification stations got done anyway I
got everything I needed out of it Loney
what a load of fortress fork titanium
come on feed me oh you don't have the
titanium give-give Steven this is all
you got Christine you better yes I knew
Christine wouldn't hold out on me oh yes
oh jeez I didn't realize that it was
like this okay yes yes okay I'm just
gonna deconstruct this get the materials
back oh cool lots of good stuff okay now
I go over here now I build the aquarium
how do I get in it do I get in from
outside Oh
where do I put it where do I put it
where do I put it on here can I put it
on top oh please tell me I can put it on
top
oh I sound like a kid in the candy store
over very perverted man oh can I put it
up here no dammit dammit okay
that doesn't matter it's okay oh and
it's so cool I mean I mean I mean water
this is the fact that I'm in water I'm
in the ocean anyway alright so there
that's that
I'm gonna see if I can put the creature
eggs in here not the bad matters but
it's just something it's something
huh-uh use planter Oh
Oh
but I can put I can put some of my
unique plants that I got I'm just gonna
drop one in here just just because I can
and it's weird that it just kind of
floats in midair like that totally fine
but oh oh that's cool so I got a weird
mysterious egg floating in the middle of
my aquarium and I'm gonna try to put
other fish in there but I'm gonna save
that for another episode so we did a lot
of good here let's just review we got
yuki christine parker and steven thank
you all so much for commenting and I
appreciate you guys supporting my series
and I've got a whole bunch of other
stuff to do I'm gonna add more glass
which is gonna in turn weaken my whole
place but I'm gonna add more glass there
and I got my observation room there and
I'm gonna Park the USS [ __ ] the ocean
right by the observation Basin no one's
gonna mess with it so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what I should do in the next video
but I've already got an idea of one of
them do it I might record it for this
but thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video I want to join
this club